o lado pessoal do que falar andar que
sejam muito bem vindos é mais um bebê e
os estragos de que a dar esse moleque eu
acho que sim se não sair o chivas
garantiu por algum tempo e acabei por
fazer um vídeo por isso se vocês
quiserem mais firme nos comentários e já
agora em cinema jogar porque eu não sei
muito bem o jogo mexe eu tentei então é
espero que vocês gostem embora lá pelas
cinco gols interromper o cais uma andar
e eu continuo sem saber o que é que isto
é o meu deus que me vamos fazer rap
agora estou aqui no jogo de andar e tu
sabes como é que eu vou rimar oboé
eu vim de amigos eu vejo naruto não sabe
jogar isto é um funk em aborto porque tu
és com senpai justiça eo país sofre sua
mãe quem aposte que nas minhas cuecas
o que é isto kiko é que é esta nós temos
que conquistar o não se um pai com os
nossos colegas que belo jogo agora gosto
agora só percebi porque é que tanta
gente diz garante o bom nível escrevi
aqui então é que mais sexy e eu acho que
quanto mais sexy e dos manguinhos ou é
dos moranguinhos o euro sim está difícil
escolher uma cueca de 60 que papai andar
é um super show que nesta quarta a mãe
estavam sem pai acha que no futuro a fia
eu não tenho fotografia em um único tiro
fotografias um detalhe que merecem pai
que bonito
estamos na escola preenchimento está o
carro da minha mãe vai oferecer quando
capturar o sem pai fica quando pra
sempre fazer muitos filhos aqui aquela
criança aquela que é um holograma ela
corrige o início e com coisa banal
pauzinho absurda a mim com o tico liga
num site islâmico
vamos treinar juntas quer o maior de uma
pessoa por dentro de mim adoro eu quero
um sem pai
o lacen país.com posso falar contigo sem
pai sem pai não quer falar comigo
ninguém falou que não é tal que incluiu
fora momento o que eu posso fazer com
ela porque as pessoas passam dentro de
mim aí vão me falar que aquela menina
que ela parece que quer falar com alguém
é elas contêm costuma usar por sempre
querem festa era o que é aquilo a uma
ceni tem uma da escola eu posso usar
isto é relva precisa de ser limpa porque
sempre vai passar e que mais tarde não
precisa ficar impressionado com as
coisas eu quero meu caso ou dúvidas
qualquer
é uma honra receber o meu deus venci
oeste cruise com água a a água tão
bonito tirar uma foto shannon
integrantes podem surgir te ato proibido
eu preciso demonstrar as cuecas não quer
ver as minhas colegas
ae ap milão conquistou meu coração eu
preciso encontrar alguma coisa dentro da
escola que faça conquistaram sem pai e
não a ver o que se passa aqui mas delas
são bem melhores do que as minhas e eu
acho que é melhor não implica o santos
não é ainda morava em praia mim o que eu
tenho que fazer para conquistar o
sampaio não sair tão em baixo sem pai e
sem mãe sem pai não fugir de você ir até
a casa do amigo pode olhar para mim com
aquele lixo ou mais funky gol eu posso
chegar e humanas
gosto e jô o texto tem água
eu quero pegar o posto que era escola
maravilhosa um ou outro é quilo nesta
não quero ser pai que era umas em man
não posso falar com ela porque posso
ficar isto um selim eu posso fingir
estar aqui todos uma advogada agora tem
várias não não pode eu consegui passar
tudo eu sou o sufoquem fantasma a já
possuía e eu acho que tem que falar com
várias pessoas com a minha reputação
subida
eu acho que é isso porque quanto mais
gente conhecer eu acho que mais uns 100
pai está em mim
ok eu preciso conquistar o meu sem pai e
teve 8 é isso que eu me machuquei uma
cueca limpa pra hoje na época já está
toda quebrada porque eu não consegui
mandar apoiando a fox anita net fazendo
panquecas human dar apoio com esta pec é
porque vai se dividir em dois porque vai
ficar 30 anunciou que o país mude o país
manteve se calmo sem pai sempre andar
aqui ou não
muito interessante estudar isso não tá
me colocou no chão
a fox tem armas o que para usar nos
matar esta [ __ ] toda
muitas pessoas não gostam de mim você
pai que nada comigo por isso o coma tudo
o que quero é que ela era minha amiga de
uma tânia anda cá não estão ao seu pai
não pode ser
também vamos embora vamos matar as
professoras cachorro torque
o xix
ok sem pai é sempre o primeiro a chegar
à escola o próprio tirando foto ser pai
eu estou aqui para iniciá lá eu nunca
paro em mim porque - o grande gaza
gostoso e um olha pra mim por causa que
eu não consigo comer o seu pai morre
filha da mãe que já não tens aí né não
foi nada aconteceu e não fiz nada é só
matar aquela porta que andava comigo no
meu país vocês souberem como é que
conquistou foi em sampa e ligou e nos
comentários porque não faz idéia de como
é que conquistar o período viu e ouviu
ou viu uma pessoa que mantém o maior
foco no engodo não forjassem pai estou
aqui pra tiro imagine esta gaja cobriu
vamos pra trás da escola não teve uma
conversa
o els caconde santana por funk eu sabia
que era um demônio o que é preciso para
de sangue não podem saber que fui eu